chaos and scale have always been the
foundation of the Battlefield franchise
and battlefield 5 is no different squads
of soldiers relentlessly push towards
objectives with either shear force or
improvised tactics while gunfire and
explosions ring throughout the beautiful
but war-torn landscapes it's an
overwhelming sensory experience and for
the most part a fine execution of a
familiar formula
battlefield 5 goes back to World War 2
zero peon theater as a backdrop for
first-person shooting and vehicular
combat in large multiplayer matches not
too dissimilar from battlefield one
where every weapon has a distinct weight
and impact that comes through vividly in
both sight and sound the core of
battlefield remains mostly untouched but
small tweaks are welcome additions
ground troops are even more deadly this
time around with a revamped ballistics
model that results in reduced time to
kill for skilled players all players
regardless of class can revive squad
mates which highly encouraged is
sticking together but it doesn't negate
the importance of the medic classes
instant revive class roles and teamwork
are further emphasized by the attrition
system the change is made to resource
scarcity the support classes ammo
distribution comes in clutch when you
survive multiple firefights while the
assault class has a perk that grants
more ammo upon scavenging the game's
health system is partially auto
regenerating but relies on having a med
kit on hand distributed by medics as
impactful as attrition sounds it's not
so overbearing as to drastically
shake-up battlefield score though it
does make going rogue less viable
the fortification system lets you build
predetermined structures like sandbag
walls barbed wire coils and Czech
hedgehogs there are no resources tied to
this though the support class builds
much faster than others and could prop
up things like stationary guns overall
it feels a bit tacked on but there's no
denying its effectiveness in the right
situation sandbags for a little cover
can go a long way for holding down an
objective when everything else has been
reduced to rubble above all else
battlefield 5 truly shines in Grand
Operations a series of three consecutive
matches or rounds intertwine by brief
narrative bits inspired by world war two
events the dress-up is a nice touch but
the real reason Grand Operations works
is because it keeps up the momentum from
round to round and packages focused
well-executed modes like airborne
breakthrough in frontlines frontlines in
particular plays out like a tug of war
where teams fight over different
objectives in sequential order within
defined sections of a map depending on
the phase of the match this game type
isn't entirely new however the mechanics
built around battlefield 5 along with
the shift in map dynamics in each phase
makes the game an absolute thrill to
play it naturally ushers a team's
attention to a handful of clear
objectives and provides a method to the
madness
creating a satisfying push and pull
where success feels earned unfortunately
the series staple of conquest has become
the weakest link which has devolved into
a match long carousel a flag captures
easy kills and cheap deaths most maps
feel too condensed and disjointed for
the high player count and mechanics of
conquest you're often caught from behind
or flanked by enemies that simply
stumble upon you it goes both ways as
you'll often find enemies squads with
their backs turn because you lucked into
a certain spawn and ran in the right
direction there are a few bugs in
battlefield 5 some that are forgivable
like wild ragdoll physics but some are
more problematic rarely would you have
to revive a squad made by a door but
you're likely to only get the prompt to
interact with the door instead of
reviving on very rare occasions the map
goes blank when trying to enlarge it or
health facts just don't work thankfully
it's not enough to overshadow the game's
best parts all the while you'll be
earning xp for a number of separate
progression paths there isn't a ton to
unlock but levelling up weapon
proficiencies
to customize them to your play style and
various weapons and pieces of equipment
unlock as you rank up classes it's a
fairly sensible system though the same
can't be said about vehicles since
they're hard to come by and each one
ranks up separately customizing each
class's appearance is where Cosmetics
like different uniforms and weapon skins
come into play it's also how company
coins factor in the in-game currency
that you earn through challenges like
daily orders or assignments or finishing
matches most cosmetics can be acquired
with company coins but you should note
that weapon and vehicle perks are also
types of company coins at least a
relatively low cost there are no micro
transactions at the moment but are said
to be implemented in the future for
cosmetics only battlefield 5 isn't
solely a multiplayer endeavor with the
return of war stories the single-player
campaign it attempts to present a more
earnest tone to a brutal conflict and
highlight lesser-known parts of world
war two like the Norwegian resistance
and the Senegalese Ti lowers who fought
for the French army amid racial
discrimination the effort is admirable
especially when it comes to the tier I
lower campaign the mix of stealth in
combat and Nord Lee's as a one-person
army can be fun and showcases some of
the game's best set pieces but the
English side is an eye rolling series of
tedious missions that goes for a more
lighthearted tone that doesn't work war
stories has its moments but it's all
over the place in terms of design tone
and style currently battlefield 5 still
has features to implement as part of its
game as a service approach designated
tides of war
it's an exciting prospect that there's a
lot more to come at no additional cost
but you can't help but feel that the
launch package could have been a bit
more dense and unfortunately we won't be
able to evaluate those parts of the game
until they arrive the series has a
winning formula that battlefield 5
doesn't deviate far from at least for
now conquest and the map roster don't
mesh well together
however grand operations and the other
modes within it steal the show and
create some of the greatest moments the
franchise is offered you might be
surprised by the impact of the slight
changes made for this game especially
when you're deep into pushing objectives
and frontlines alongside teammates
fulfilling their roles
that's when battlefield 5 is at its best